if they're right if conservatives if
republicans just aren't going to be
serious about winning
maybe it's just a controlled opposition
and we're just going to have a managed
decline politically and that's why i
wanted to go into business it's like i
could actually do something
you know you could start and invest in
startups and if we can get technology to
work sort of faster than government can
[ __ ] progress then maybe we can have a
good future uh so
you know i basically thought it was all
over honestly until 2016.
all right we are in studio and joining
me today is the co of teal capital
the co-author of zero to one which i
keep on the set normally right over
there
and the next senator from the great
state of arizona blake masters
welcome to the reuben report thank you
it's great to be here i'm glad to have
you man i've wanted to do this for a
while we wanted to do it in person yes
as i said you are the co-author of that
book which i think was really one of
sort of formative things for me to get
involved in the tech
world and all of that and i know that's
obviously something that interests you a
lot so why don't we start
there how do you start working with teal
and getting some of these ideas across
about making new things yeah well i was
a student at stanford law school and i
remember my friend said hey peter thiel
you know the founder of paypal i was
going to teach a class and so we should
take that class and i didn't know that
much about peter then i knew it was
libertarian businessman you know
billionaire uh time to paypal that
seemed cool um good so he was into
seasteading you know this idea that you
should maybe think about how to start
new countries
we should get back we'll talk about that
actually so he seemed like a cool guy
and uh you know what an opportunity to
take a class from someone who wasn't
just a professor you know i actually
done something in the world so i took uh
he i took that class and sort of
befriended peter this was my second year
in law school i went to go intern for
him at his venture capital fund
that summer and then he came back taught
another class my last year in law school
i took really good notes on that class i
just basically typed down everything he
said
because i liked the first class but i
can't tell you too much about it because
it's all lost to memory right i wasn't
like a big note taker in college because
who cares um but the second time i was
prepared so i wrote down everything
peter said
cleaned it up posted it online
and these notes became kind of like a
phenomenon in silicon valley this was
like 2012. because i think it was the
first time uh you could actually kind of
collect all of peter's thoughts on
building a startup that's what the class
was about startups and technology
companies and how to do new things in a
stagnant society and so i think people
who are interested in peter at the time
and his stock was sort of rising like
facebook was just about to ipo um you
could piece together things from like
interviews print interviews youtube but
there was no one set of like here's
peter thiel's thoughts on how to start a
startup all of a sudden me as this
random stanford student was publishing
this online and so silicon valley a
couple thousand people just started
following week over week
these notes and became this really
successful so you were doing it in real
time i was doing class putting the notes
up and people were following so
basically they were getting the
education for free that's right
alongside which is really interesting
because it was this awesome class and
you know i think we ultimately turned it
into a very successful book but i think
it would have just died like all the
material and like you know peter worked
hard to to organize all the thinking for
the class but uh if it's not recorded if
it doesn't
you know actually get outside the
classroom it just dies there and that
would have been a big shame yeah so the
the basic premise of the book is that
the next facebook is not going to be
facebook to go to from zero to one you
have to do something fully new right
does that feel more
sort of relevant now than it did even
you know eight ten years ago because of
the sort of upheaval and weird spot that
we're in right now it does i think we
desperately do need new technology to
sort of take things to the next level we
have a remarkably stagnant society
i think people get distracted like the
iphone 13 pro just came out it's like
congratulations the camera is much
better and that's cool wait it's a half
inch bigger or bigger
bigger better it's good enough we
literally just shot a campaign ad in
cinema mode on iphone 13 pro and it's
like holy [ __ ] this is actually a really
good camera so there's some innovation
but it's also marginal and this is all
confined to sort of your smartphone or
sort of it broadly or software startups
um actually society looks so much like
it did in the 1970s like we're not
moving faster in some ways we're moving
slower you know we don't build houses
any better or more efficiently now um
actually housing prices are just going
through the roof right so so much in our
society is stagnant and zero to one is
yeah narrowly a business book but
broadly it's the sort of exploration of
why
is so much
of our society just stagnant like why
can't we do new things is that kind of
the core of why you want to go into
politics or is it fair to say you even
want to go into politics in a way where
you're being sort of dragged to politics
i sense that with a lot of people that
are getting involved it was like i
didn't really want to be a politician at
first but somebody's got to fix this
somebody's going to have somebody i
definitely have that that view of it um
i mean
i'm getting into it i really want to get
into it i think it's important you know
i'm i'm loving campaigning i want i'm
going to win the race so i'm i just told
everybody you just told everyone so
that's going to happen yeah you're right
but it'd be it'd be nice in some sense
like if i didn't have to like if things
were working if we didn't have this
establishment that was presiding over i
think this cultural and and uh economic
decay
then i wouldn't have to but that's not
where we are and i have to and i think
we need some new thinking in government
so it's also
the most important thing i could be
doing i didn't think this was the case
in like 2012 uh when i was taking those
notes i thought um
you know i saw mitt romney lose to
barack obama and it's like how could
this possibly happen i thought the first
obama term was so bad that of course
like a successful businessman governor
mitt romney you know he even looks the
part of course he's gonna win he
definitely looks like and then it was
just uh i think he was too nice and um
just
sort of failed to understand this was a
fight for the future of the country and
he lost and to me
uh i've always been political but sort
of like well if the if they're right if
conservatives if republicans just aren't
going to be serious about winning um
maybe it's just the controlled
opposition and we're just going to have
a managed decline politically and that's
why i wanted to go into business it's
like i could actually do something
you know you could start and invest in
startups and if we can get technology to
work sort of faster than government can
[ __ ] progress then maybe we can have a
good future
so
you know i basically thought it was all
over honestly until 2016 and trump comes
on the scene and sort of busts up the
establishment and whatever your view of
that is like he did it i think it's
great i thought the administration was
very successful but he showed me that
new things are possible in politics
and i think we need much more of a
startup mentality because we have too
much stagnation too much bureaucracy um
we're really drowning in it yeah so it's
just time for i never i've never thought
about it this way but would you consider
trump in 2016 is sort of a zero to one
moment totally impossible absolutely
absolutely um he came i thought it was
it was sort of refreshing it was really
honest i mean i think this is why he was
elected he was like the one person
telling the truth which is this left
establishment and the right
establishment uh it doesn't work like
people you know he he it was the emperor
has no clothes where he's just like you
you you you're getting screwed you're
getting ripped off china's eating our
lunch you know and he'd been remarkably
consistent about that decade over decade
and uh i think people
that that resonated with them like the
election that we deserved in 2016 was
trump versus bernie sanders which of
course the dnc wouldn't let happen and
they rigged it so that bernie couldn't
win but um and i disagree with bernie
sanders on everything i think he's just
wrong like that left wing sort of
communist politics like that doesn't
work but bernie was at least more honest
than hillary cause he came on the scene
and said like this is this is rigged
this isn't a this is establishment is
failing people and that's what trump's
message was too they just had very
different uh policy prescriptions and i
think trumps are much better do you kind
of admire the sort of evilness of the
dnc in a way like that they rigged it
against bernie and admirers admire is
too strong well admire the way i always
respect it and sort of well admired like
the way the doctor admired the alien in
the first alien movie you know it was so
merciless that it was killing everything
and it had no remarks look the
the left is serious about power and they
know how to play the game and again
that's there's something horrible about
that but
they play to win and so
often republicans don't play to win we
play to be mr nice guy and then try to
get some cinecure at some think tank you
know when we lose
and i think people are just sick of that
because our backs against the wall
there's no more room to play defense if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell